hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show where in this video we're going to
talk
all about alpha-ketoglutarate and its
potential
anti-aging properties and so this video
will mainly be talking about this recent
exciting publication alpha ketoglutarate
and endogenous metabolites extends
lifespan and compresses morbidity
in aging mice and in this paper they
have evidence that
seems to support both an extension in
lifespan
and even more significantly extension of
health span
in mice just by supplementing with
alpha-ketoglutarate
so in this video we'll begin with a
discussion of what actually is
alpha-ketoglutarate
and then we'll look at the results of
this recent publication to see
the impact of taking alpha-ketoglutarate
and then we'll kind of talk about
how and why this might have happened and
then we'll talk about whether this could
also be extended to
help extend human health span so aging
affects all of us
and is also a risk factor for multiple
morbidities
including cancer and alzheimer's disease
given the current predicted changes in
demographics
the healthcare sector is particularly
vulnerable to be able to deal with all
these increases in the number of people
with different diseases
so there's a lot of hope and excitement
at the moment of instead of
developing treatments for these
different diseases separately
that instead we can target aging and
effectively
reduce the risk of all of these
different diseases reducing the burden
on the healthcare sector
and potentially finding a more
cost-effective strategy so how does
alpha-ketoglutarate fit into this
situation
well this is alpha-ketoglutarate or akg
as i refer to from now on so maybe it
doesn't look that impressive
or maybe it even looks a bit scary but
akg
is an essential metabolite within our
cells it is best known for its role
within the krebs cycle
which is a cycle that is essential for
the oxidation of fatty acids amino acids
and glucose
to generate the reductive form of nad
plus nadh
which can then be used by the
mitochondria to generate
atp which is the energy source of a cell
but the list
doesn't end there akg is involved in
loads of processes and so akg can also
be
converted into glutamate and
subsequently glutamine
and the latter are both amino acids and
so it can help stimulate protein
synthesis
and also help inhibit protein
degradation in muscle
akg can also act as a cofactor for
different enzymes
one of which is prolo4 hydroxylase this
helps to generate 4-hydroxyproline which
is really important in the generation of
collagen
and collagen we know is involved in the
generation of tendons ligaments
skin and muscle studies have also shown
that akg has many anti-oxidative
functions as well
part of this is mediated through akg's
role in detoxifying
ammonia ammonia is toxic for a cell
and akg aids in the conversion of
ammonia into
urea which can then be eliminated
through urine
another way that akg is involved in
antioxidant functions
is through the decomposition of hydrogen
peroxide
hydrogen peroxide is another toxic
molecule for the cell
and it's thought that akg is involved in
the detoxification
when it's converted into succinate so
what has this got to do with aging
well studies have shown that akg levels
decline as we age
as you can see in this figure the levels
of akg are lower in the older mice than
the younger mice
and so restoration of akg through
supplementation
may have beneficial effects for
anti-aging
for example this nature paper looked at
the impact of supplementing
akg in worms and they found that akg
delayed aging and extended the lifespan
of these worms by around 50 percent
interestingly though
the worms did not see an extension of
lifespan with akg when they were already
dietary restricted
and so this suggests that the mechanism
through which akg is acting
is through a similar pathway to that of
which dietary restriction is acting
and the pathway that the authors of this
paper suggest is the case
is the mtor pathway which is a pathway
that promotes cellular growth
so in this recent publication they
decided to test the impact of
alpha-ketoglutarate
on mice and to examine the changes
within lifespan and also healthspan
and so the work for this publication has
come from the lab of dr brian kennedy
when he was at the bach institute for
research and aging
and his lab was searching for compounds
that were generally recognized as safe
but had the potential to influence aging
and mammals
so given the previous work on akg and
also the fact it is generally recognized
as safe
this provided some motivation to examine
the impacts of akg supplementation on
mice
so what did they actually do in this
study so we can see here the
experimental setup for the study
and so this was done in both male and
female mice
and akg supplementation at 2 weight by
weight began
at 18 months of age and so in human
years that would be roughly between
the ages of 50 and 60 years old and for
both male and female mice there were two
different cohorts
so there was a lot of mice in the study
and in addition to just
looking at when natural death occurred
during this time periods
they also took measurements to examine
the
health span of the different mice and
the way they did this was by using
a clinically relevant frailty index that
takes into account 31 different
measurements
so what did they see well if we begin by
looking at
the lifespan of the male and female mice
we can see that
within the female mice there was a
significant
increase in both median lifespan and
survival
by 16.6 and 19.7 percent
in the first cohort and 10.5 and 8
in the second cohort and they also did
see
an improved survival for the male mice
as well but it wasn't significant in
both
cohorts but the main results that the
authors of this paper
promote most in this publication is the
fact that the reduction in frailty was
actually more dramatic than the
increases in lifespan that they saw
and so they suggest that this akg is
actually being able to compress
morbidity in the mice
so how do they actually examine health
span so as i mentioned
they did this by a frailty score whereby
the higher the number of this
score the mouse is more at risk to
adverse health outcomes
so this reality index takes into account
a variety of different measurements
and they include measurements such as
visual factors such as losses
of fur color as well as physical factors
such as the tail stiffening and any gait
disorders
also looking at their breathing rates
and any hearing loss any visual loss as
well as any signs of discomfort
so examining health span is notoriously
quite challenging to do
and we'll come back to this a little bit
later on but let's firstly look at
the results that they did see in the
study so what they saw was
akg treatment decreased the severity of
multiple aging phenotypes in the females
and this included pillow erection their
pain assessments
and loss of fair color and their grip
strength floss
just a couple of examples and in the
males they saw
that grip strength loss gait disorder
their hearing loss and
poor cope condition were all decreased
when they were supplemented with
akg and i think one of the most striking
results is this um difference in
the loss of the coat condition so if we
look at these images here we can see
akg treated mice on the left and control
mice on the right
and there's some quite you know striking
visual differences
in the coat color and the thickness of
the coats
and if we just focus on the female mice
in the first cohort
they actually saw a potential reversal
in
age-dependent hair graying just by akg
treatment
however it's important to point out that
not all phenotypes were improved by akg
treatment for example the treated mice
failed to perform better in a treadmill
exhaustion test
and showed no cardiac functional
improvement but
these weren't considered significant
adverse changes
and maybe they don't outweigh the
benefits that we do see with akg
treatments
but as a biochemist what kind of
explains or underpins why akg could be
having this impact
well to get a better mechanistic insight
to the beneficial effects of akg
the authors decided to look at some
inflammatory markers
in the plasma of some of the female mice
and so if we look at this figure here we
can see that there seems to be a general
suppression
of secretion of these different
inflammatory markers and this was
consistent with previous findings in
young pigs that received akg that also
saw reduction
in inflammation and so interestingly
inflammatory factors are secreted by
senescent cells
and senescent cells are cells that have
undergone a process of cell cycle arrest
and developed this secretory phenotype
that include these inflammatory factors
and based on some infantry studies the
authors found that
whilst akg didn't prevent the
development of senescence
it did reduce the inflammatory secretion
so it would be interesting to see
further studies that further explore
how akg could be mediating this effect
so as i said earlier
understanding healthspan or at least
measuring healthspan is notoriously
quite challenging to do
and whilst this study does a good effort
in terms of describing the frailty index
i think it fails to miss for example
some cognitive assessments
during aging which would be really
interesting to see and how akg could
impact that
and another way to measure health span
could be by determining biological
age and so effectively biological age
differs from chronological age which is
the time passed since birth and instead
focuses on a time dependent component
of an organism's overall health and one
way you can measure biological age
is based on epigenetic marks referred to
as an epigenetic clock
and interestingly epigenetics also is
related to akg
so epigenetics refers to modifications
on top of the dna sequence
and some of these marks include
methylation of
dna in particular of cytosine residues
and alpha ketoglutarates plays a key
role in demethylation
of some of these sites as it acts as a
cofactor for a family of enzymes
referred to as tet proteins that
actually catalyze this demethylation
so it'd be interesting to see if any of
these mice actually had changes in the
epigenetic marks
however it wasn't assessed in the study
interestingly though
the company sponsoring the research has
published some data from customers
taking its akg supplements
showing a referral on biological age as
measured by dna methylation
so this is actual human data obviously
this wasn't a randomized controlled
clinical trial
but in a recent press release the
company have announced that they're
currently conducting a randomized
double-blinded placebo
controlled clinical trial so i think
we'll just have to kind of wait and see
uh if akg does have an impact in humans
and effective as an anti-aging compound
moreover i think it'll be interesting to
see more research into the mechanism by
which
akg is potentially having this
anti-aging effect
in particular what i haven't mentioned
so far are studies that have shown
akg to be able to influence potentially
the gut microbiome composition so
there's plenty of stuff still to
investigate and understand about
what initially seemed to be such a
simple molecule and also another
exciting thing would be to try and
understand
whether or not akg could be used in
combination with
other anti-aging compounds such as
analytics
and nad precursors so hopefully this has
given you a good understanding of this
recent publication
and hopefully you've learned something
and as always thanks for listening